today on the matt wells show the big
tech giants are waging an all-out war to
suppress damaging stories about joe
biden right before the election we're
facing a very dangerous moment
and though conservatives like myself
don't like to think in these terms
it is time for the government to step in
it's long been time in fact
we'll talk about that also five
headlines including more faux
controversies coming out of the amy
coney barrett hearings those are always
fun
and in our daily cancellation it's
finally time for me to cancel barbie
that's a very important segment of the
show we'll get to that soon but first
maybe less important
news than barbie but still two major
stories happening here
the first is the series of alleged
revelations stemming from
according to new york post reports a
trove of documents emails videos and
other files which will recover from a
laptop
dropped off but never picked up from a
computer repair store in delaware
here's the new york post uh reading now
the
the computer was dropped off at a repair
shop in biden's home state of delaware
in april 2019 according to the store's
owner
the customer who brought in the water
damage macbook pro for repair
never paid for the service or retrieved
it or a hard drive a hard drive on which
its contents were stored
according to the shop owner who said he
tried to repeatedly to contact the
client
the shop owner couldn't positively
identify the customer as hunter biden
but said the laptop bore a sticker from
the beau biden foundation
named after hunter's late brother and
former delaware attorney general
photos of a delaware federal subpoena
given to the post
show that the both the computer and the
hard drive were seized by the fbi in
december
after the shop's owner says he alerted
the feds to their existence
but before turning over the gear the
shop owner says he made a copy of the
hard drive and later gave it to
former mayor rudy giuliani's lawyer
robert costello
steve bannon former advisor to president
trump
told the post about the existence of the
hard drive in late september
and giuliani provided the the post with
the copy of it on sunday okay
so that's that's the post report on how
the information came to light
as for the information itself uh i'll
read a little bit of that to you i can't
post this stuff on twitter or facebook
but
i can read it to you at least so i'll
give you some of it um this in an
article titled
smoking gun email reveals how hunter
biden
introduced ukrainian businessman to vp
dad in this article we're told
quote hunter biden introduced his father
then vice president joe biden to a top
executive at a ukrainian energy
firm less than a year before the elder
biden pressured government officials
in ukraine into firing a prosecutor who
was investigating the company
according to emails obtained by the post
the never before revealed meeting is
mentioned in a message of appreciation
that vadim pozarsky an advisor to the
board of brisbane
allegedly sent hunter biden on april
17th 2015.
about a year after hunter joined the
barisma board at a reported salary of up
to fifty thousand dollars a month
pretty nice deal if you can get it says
dear hunter thank you for inviting me to
dc and giving an opportunity to meet
your father
and spend some time together it's really
an honor and pleasure
the email reads an earlier email from
may 2014 also shows posarski reportedly
burisma's number three executive asking
hunter for advice on how you could use
your influence on the company's behalf
the blockbuster correspondence which
flies in the face of joe biden's claim
that he's never spoken to his son about
his overseas business dealings
which never made sense anyway by the way
i mean just in general you're a dad you
never talk to your son about what he's
doing in his business doesn't make sense
anyway
back to the port it says uh this is all
contained in a massive trove of data
recovered from a laptop computer
okay now another article from new york
post has this headline
emails reveal how hunter biden tried to
cash in big on behalf of family with
chinese firm
the report reads hunter biden pursued
lucrative deals involving china's
largest private energy company
including one that he said would be
interesting for me and my family
emails obtained by the post show one
email sent to biden on may 13th
2017 with the subject line expectations
included details of
remuneration packages for six people
involved in an unspecified business
venture biden was identified as chair
slash vice chair depending on agreement
with c-e-c-e-f-c
an apparent reference to the former
shanghai-based conglomerate
cefc china energy company his pay was
packed
was pegged at 8.50 and the email also
noted that hunter has some
office expectations that he will
elaborate in addition
the email outlined a provisional
agreement under which 80 percent of the
equity or shares in the new company
would be split equally among four people
whose initials correspond to the sender
and three recipients
with h apparently referring to biden the
the deal also mentions
or or lists 10 gym and 10 held by
h for the big guy neither jim nor the
big guy was identified
all right now there's a lot more to
these stories and i'd suggest going to
the new york post website
reading it for yourself there are other
alleged revelations too lots of stuff
about hunter you know allegedly
um doing drugs and cavorting with
hookers and so on i don't really care
about any of that
i do care and everybody should care
about hunter leveraging his connections
to the vice president
and getting involved with china and all
of the things that
point to real corruption that matters
and
what matters perhaps even more than that
has been of course the response from big
tech
because as the cliche goes you know the
cover-up is worse than the crime
and that holds here that holds true here
too i think
as you've probably heard by now twitter
and facebook together have been working
overtime to suppress and censor the new
york post reporting
about this scandal and they have
punished suspended
uh flagged people who share the stories
and that includes not just random
accounts politicians reporters officials
prominent people all being targeted by
the big social media giants for trying
to alert the public to this story
the white house press secretary was the
latest this this morning to be locked
out of her twitter account
for posting the article twitter actually
disabled the link to the story
so you couldn't read it or share it i've
never seen that before
facebook announced right away through
its spokesman that it would be reducing
access to the story
so this has been an all-out full court
press
to subpress credible reporting from a
major news publication
three weeks out from an election this is
a direct effort by these billion dollar
companies
to influence the election there's no
other way to look at it
now jack jack dorsey twitter's ceo
said last night that twitter's handling
of the situation has been
not great quote unquote but they
continue doing it
they're still doing it today the reasons
we're given
by twitter and facebook is that the
story is for one thing
they say misinformation andy stone
facebook spokesman said
um this is part of our standard process
to reduce the spread of misinformation
we temporarily reduce distribution
pending fact checker review
standard process right also we're told
that the story violates alleged policies
against publishing hacked material
and publishing material obtained without
consent the twitter safety account
tweeted
quote the policy established in 2018
prohibits the use of our service to
distribute content obtained without
authorization
we don't want to incentivize hacking by
allowing twitter to be used as
distribution for possibly illegally
obtained materials
now notice something okay the story is
suppressed
based both on being misinformation
and being hacked material well how can
it be both if hunter's computer was
hacked
then it's not misinformation it's real
but if the story is made up
then it's not hacked material in reality
of course it appears that it's neither
hacked nor misinformation
it appears the emails are real um
that's what it appears anyway and they
were on a computer that allegedly was
abandoned
so that's not hacking but my point is
that it can't be both
misinformation and hacked what is it
hacked
misinformation so let's look at
let's look at these excuses one at a
time though misinformation again
no reason to think that this is
misinformation but regardless
do facebook and twitter have a
consistent policy
and record of suppressing misinformation
or claims that are dubiously sourced
of course not not even close not
remotely dozens of examples come
immediately to mind like for example
every
anonymously source trump story we've
ever seen
every week there's another claim from
some anonymous person
alleging this or that about donald trump
people in the white house go on the
record denying it
are those reports ever censored banned
taken down
flagged as harmful no
but here's an even better example every
time
there's a police shooting immediately
wild claims are made based on no
evidence
or in direct contradiction of the
evidence this goes all the way back to
the debunked hands up don't shoot stuff
up
and all the way up to now every time
there's a shooting social media is used
to advance the claim
that the cop is a racist serial killer
out hunting black men
there's never any evidence of this it is
always
always misinformation and the direct
consequence of the misinformation can be
seen in the form of
smoldering buildings and dead people
twitter and facebook have never flagged
any of that
never suppressed it what about
distributing content obtained without
without authorization again
dozens of examples spring immediately to
mind how about trump's tax returns
how about secret audio recordings of
melania trump
those were not only posted twitter to
twitter but trended proudly for days
there was no news value to them none it
was it was an invasion of privacy
and released solely to embarrass the
first lady that's the only reason
twitter made no attempt at all to
restrict access to it quite the opposite
in fact
and besides plenty of legitimate
reporting involves content obtained
without authorization
by this standard nearly every major
political news story over the last
50 years wouldn't be allowed on the
platform
when's the last time a politician
explicitly consented to the publication
of material that would damage him
politically
so this standard is nonsensical and
applied unevenly
very unevenly to put it mildly speaking
of unevenly today
guess what was trending on twitter while
the hunter biden story is shut down
one of the top trends was hashtag eric
trump's
ukraine scandal eric trump's ukraine
scandal
that's insane it's flat out election
interference flat out
listen i believe in private property
rights but i also believe
that billion dollar corporations that
control the flow of information should
not be allowed to employ fraud and
subterfuge
in order to influence the outcome of
elections that's where i stand
and i note that many of the people
preaching about the rights of twitter
also have spent the last eight years
telling us that small-town bakeries who
don't want to make
custom wedding cakes for gay weddings
are waging a dangerous assault on
freedom and democracy
no that's exactly the other way around
there is zero
danger to the public zero danger if your
local baker doesn't want to put
figurines of two dudes on top of a
wedding cake
you could do it yourself it causes no
harm to anyone
it is completely irrelevant the only
thing it hurts
maybe is your fragile feelings but
twitter and facebook are multi-billion
dollar companies they are not
bakeries this is much more in line with
you know your phone company cutting off
service because it doesn't like the
political opinions you express while on
the phone
it is that sort of danger only worse
much worse because people
these days um do a lot more
communicating on social media than they
do through telephone calls
and that's why it's time for
conservatives like myself to get over
our visceral disgust at the idea of
government involvement in anything
um and we have to just get over that
there is no free market solution to this
problem there isn't
unless you have 100 billion dollars to
throw around you aren't going to go out
and make your own facebook it's just not
going to happen it can't happen
so we have to decide whether we want to
live in a world where big tech giants
run
society and decide elections or if
measures should be taken to regulate
them
and hold them to a basic standard of
honesty and fairness
that is the question we face
let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
well you know nobody likes spending
hours at the uh at the
auto body shop every every you know
every time you have a problem with your
car you got to go you got to get in your
car
drive over there and what happens you
get there and they don't have what you
need anyway
rockauto.com is so much easier so much
easier than walking into a store
asking you know dealing with all the
questions they ask and everything else
and they're not gonna have what you want
they gotta they're gonna have to order
it online anyway why not cut out the
middleman go to rockauto.com you carry
it around in your pocket
you've got it at your desk on your
laptop just go there rockauto.com always
offers the lowest prices possible
they're not going to change their prices
they're not going to try to you know
milk you for all your worth
um they're going to give you the lowest
the lowest possible price if you're
getting it on rockauto.com
you could be confident that it's the
best price this is the best you're going
to get
rockauto.com is a family business
they've been serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years
go to rockauto.com to shop for auto and
body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers
best of all again prices at rockauto.com
reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers
you don't have to spend twice as much
for the same parts don't spend twice as
much for the same parts or twice as much
for you know a worse selection of parts
anyway
go to rockauto.com right now see all the
parts available for your car truck
and write walsh in there how did you
hear about his box
so they know that we sent you okay
number one early voting is underway and
um
record turnouts are being reported
here's a story from the news times it
says with less than three weeks to go
before the november
third election more than 14 million
americans
have voted in the fall election
reflecting an extraordinary level of
participation
despite barriers being erected by the
coronavirus pandemic in georgia this
week
voters waited as long as 11 hours to
cast their ballots on the first day of
early voting
in north carolina nearly one in five of
roughly 500
000 who have returned mail ballots did
not vote in the last presidential
election
in michigan more than a million people
have already voted and then it goes on
to say much of the early voting seems to
be driven by
enthusiasm among democrats so you know
you could
believe that or not take it with a grain
of salt i know a lot of my my listeners
maybe don't want to
don't want to hear this but there does
appear to be a lot of enthusiasm among
voters who hate trump
and want him gone this this is what i
expected i expected a massive
anti-trump turnout that's gonna happen
it didn't happen in 2016 there was not a
massive anti-trump turnout and i think
i think part of the reason for that is
that everyone thought he'd lose anyway
and um also because hillary clinton was
so
just unappealing as a human being
you might say biden is unappealing too
but it's it's not to the level of
hillary
nobody is at the level of hillary
clinton clinton when it comes to be
comes to being
viscerally unappealing right so um
that's the way things are trending the
good news is that the election isn't
over yet there are still three weeks to
go
but as i've been saying for a long time
now trump needs to do something make
some kind of
pitch have some kind of strategy
to mobilize other than just the maga
crowd
yeah you need the mega crowd you've
already got them
that's good you're going to need more
than that
there aren't enough people who wear maga
hats to win the election you cannot you
cannot that's your base that your core
supporters great
you need more than that um he needs to
reach the sorts of people
who don't love him personally maybe
don't even like him personally
but also don't like the democrats and
right now are trying to
and i look i could be wrong this is just
my
my guess my guess is that there are a
lot of people right now
who are undecided only because not
because they're trying to choose between
trump and biden
they're trying to choose between voting
for trump or not voting at all
and so trump needs to have some sort of
a strategy for mobilizing and reaching
out to those voters
who are on the fence right now between
not voting at all at all or voting for
him he has to give them a reason to vote
for him
he needs to make those voters feel
better about voting for him
he used to do something and his norm his
normal routine with the rallies and the
tweeting and everything
that's not going to be enough and so i
am worried about this
i'm worried that three weeks from the
election i have no idea what the trump
campaign strategy is other than
just do all the same stuff he always
does that's not a campaign strategy
that again that's a that's a campaign
strategy for the people who are already
excited about you
i don't know what his strategy is for
the for the other mill
that that whole pool of millions of
people who are who are gettable you can
get them
but they're not going to come to a rally
because they're not that excited
what is this strategy for those do you
know does anyone know
it doesn't seem like there is one and
that that worries me
um i know trump kind of ad-libbed
ad-libbed his way to to to the win in
2016 very impressive
i i don't think we should assume it's
going to happen at second time
conditions are very different so i'm
concerned about that
number two during day three of the
hearing yesterday uh wednesday there was
a moment
from amy coney barrett that if she were
a liberal i'll play this for you because
if she were a liberal
this moment would already be turned into
merchandise and and t-shirts and bumper
stickers and everything else
uh here it is listen to this to be clear
as
i said i think in response to this
question yesterday
i do share justice claire's approach to
text
originalism and textualism but in the
litany of cases that you've just
identified the particular votes that
he's
he cast are a different question of
whether i would agree
with the way that he applied those
principles in particular cases
and i've already said you know and i
hope
that you aren't suggesting that i don't
have my own mind or that
i couldn't think independently or that i
would just decide like
let me see what justice scalia has said
about this in the past because i assure
you i have my own mind
um but everything that he said
um is not necessarily what i would agree
with or what i would do if i were
justice barrett that was justice scalia
so i share his philosophy but i've never
said that i
would always reach the same outcome as
he did i assure you i have my own mind
she says
that was a good moment from barrett i'm
not saying that i think it was some kind
of epic smackdown of some sort but
uh or or any kind of uh empowering
feminist anthem
i'm saying that in our vapid culture if
barrett was liberal
that's how it would be seen i mean
during the the vice presidential debate
camilla harris said um i'm speaking and
feminists turned that into you know the
most brilliant comeback
in the history of debates they turn it
into a shirt like right away you see the
shirt here
um so that's the way that goes meanwhile
another moment from the hearings
this one was also seized upon by the
left
in an incredibly dishonest way i know
that won't surprise you but
first watch watch this do you think
brown versus board of education super
president is that
you're not aware of any effort to go
back to the good old days of segregation
by a legislative body is that correct
that is correct okay so what's the news
there
not immediately obvious to a normal
person you see that you think okay
what's what's the problem
well they're making a big deal out of
the fact that lindsey graham said
good old days of segregation obviously
sarcastically in the same vein that
somebody might say
uh when they're told they need a root
canal by the dentist they might say oh
great
does anyone you hear that do you think
oh that person must love root canals
um or you know if someone says oh just
what i they you run into traffic and you
say
just what i need the way the left is
responding to what lindsey graham
i guess if they were in the car with you
they would think why do you need traffic
what are you
what are you talking about doesn't
compute um
so here's jamie harrison graham's
opponent in south carolina
he said lindsey graham just called
segregation the good old days
the good old days for who senator it's
2020 not
1920 act like it then there are articles
like this in mediaites um
it says senator lindsey graham raised
eyebrows during his questioning of judge
amy coney barrett
when he asked the supreme court nominee
how much confidence she has in the
landmark
brown versus board of education um
uh how much country she has in
i don't know this is phrase anyway
if she was asked if this was a super
president brown versus board of
education uh anyway it says curiously
however senator graham who finds himself
in a hotly contested re-election
also asked um if it's it also referred
to the good old days of segregation
the article says wait what good old days
of segregation i mean
he could have been joking despite the
lack of any facial cue or body language
suggesting sarcastic hyperbole
however senator graham got a lot of
attention during a recent debate with
his political foe jamie harrison
when he said that young black people and
immigrants could go anywhere in south
carolina but added you just need to be
conservative
um and it goes on from there just
to call this to call this merely bad
faith would be a massive understatement
yeah i'm sure you're really confused
about this aren't you i don't know was
he serious or not i have no idea
maybe he was really openly and publicly
reminiscing in a favorable way about
segregation
while on tv in a supreme court hearing
during an election
he could have been who knows
um okay let's see here there was one
other thing
one other thing i wanted to mention in
the hearings that i didn't get a chance
to yet this article from cnn uh headline
is
amy coney barrett says she owns a gun
but could fairly judge a case on gun
rights obvious implication is
she can't if she if you own a gun how
can you be fair in judging a case on gun
rights
all i'm going to say in response to this
is imagine during the sonia sotomayor
confirmation in 2009
imagine the following headline sonia
sotomayor says she's a woman
but could fairly judge a case on women's
rights
something something tells me i i sort of
doubt that you we would have ever seen
that headline i don't think we did
i could go back and check uh number
three scary stuff here tommy lee
former rock star speaking with the big
issue uh
has said that he might leave the country
if trump is reelected
here he is he says dude i swear to god
if that happens then i'm coming over to
visit the uk
i'm out of here i'll go back to my
motherland go back to greece
and get a house on one of the islands
and then he goes on from there talking
about how bad
trump is um to me the big headline here
is that tommy lee is still alive
i i honestly thought that he died years
ago i'm not i'm not trying to be funny i
really thought that
so congratulations to tommy lee first of
all on not being dead
as far as him leaving the country well
now that i know he's still alive
you know i couldn't bear to lose him
again i can't lose him twice
in fact i'll probably vote for biden
just to keep tommy lee here i am now a
single
issue voter and my issue is
making sure tommy lee does not leave us
because i i don't want to live in a
country like that i don't know about you
number four um here is uh
it's always it's always tough when you
take a politician like camila harris and
you
try to make her seem human and
but rachel maddow msnbc they did what
they could to get a human moment out of
camila harris and here's how that went
i just realized that i would kick myself
if i didn't just
ask you uh before i let you go if
you noticed the fly on vice president
pence's head
at the time during the day all right or
if that was something that only
could we could see it at home could you
see it sitting next to him
did you have feelings about like did you
have the
instinct to
you know
i just you know i think that it's
important that we kind of
um find a way all of us
to move on and you know kind of
fly away from this subject onto
something else
yeah senator harris you are very kind
and let's just spare a thought right now
for the people who have to write closed
captions
for this portion of the interview uh and
for those who have to transcribe it
because they're going to have no idea
how to convey what we just communicated
that just it makes my skin crawl doesn't
it it it's it's
almost as bad as hillary clinton trying
to pretend to be
to be you know not a robot
um that's that's tough to watch tough to
get through okay number five my producer
sent me this story i haven't read it
ahead of time
i never read this stuff ahead of time if
you can't tell um but here's the story
from
the bristol post it seems promising
headline is
man who farted in uber ends up in court
uh and then says let's see breaking
breaking wind in the back of an uber
taxi cost a man a suspended jail term
but the repercussion for the taxi driver
was that he has to return to his native
bulgaria
drunken james mallett let rip as
alexander bonchev was driving him to
chaser's nightclub in kingswood
bristol crown court heard it was the
final straw for the cabbie
who after suffering abuse abuse from
other fairs told malt to get out of the
vehicle because you know he farted to
get out of the vehicle
um and at that point mallet began
hitting the driver
and uh so then there was a fight okay so
he's
so he's not going to jail for farting in
the uber he's going to jail for
first he farts on the uber it sounds
like and then he beats up
starts beating up the uber driver um
insult to injury there and he's in and
so that's that's what
what gets him prosecuted so i was hoping
listen
i would i would be fully in favor of a
law that
penalizes people for flatulence in
certain scenarios
i think in an uber you know is is one
big one on a plane i've i have in the
past shared my own experience we've all
had experiences like this
sitting next to someone who with chronic
flatulence um
it is it is it's it's biological warfare
you shouldn't allow biological terrorism
especially on a plane and so i'd be in
favor of prosecution
in in circumstances like that sounds
like that's not what happened here
but it gives us something to aspire to
in any way um
all right we're gonna get to our daily
cancellation in just one second
but first you know small businesses have
really been taking a beating
since march with all the lockdowns and
everything and uh if you're a
business owner i don't have to tell you
you're feeling the effect you you know
how it is
so that's why we're excited to tell you
that next wednesday the daily wire god
king himself jeremy boring
is going to be presenting alongside a
team of world-renowned business leaders
at expert ownership live a two-day
virtual conference
about leading through crisis now is the
time for that the conference features a
lineup of speakers like leadership
author
john maxwell uh the benham brothers many
others the founders of duck commander
and otterbox
all of them going to be there and
they'll share their stories about their
businesses and startup journeys
tough times and more importantly they're
going to tell you how they
have navigated the trials and
tribulations of being a business owner
and
come out stronger on the other side this
conference is one of the kinds of
investments that that is really worth it
if you're a business owner
so visit expert ownership live dot com
slash walls to register for 197
buy a second ticket for a friend for 50
percent off you don't want to miss this
lineup you don't want to miss this event
don't want to miss the god king jeremy
boring again that's expert ownership
live dot com slash walsh buy one ticket
for 197.
get 150 off that's expert ownership live
dot com slash
walsh okay daily cancellation today for
our daily cancellation something that
was sent to me by one of my daily wire
colleagues who said that
they thought it'd be good fodder for the
daily cancellation and he was right uh
it is my pleasure today to cancel barbie
i've been waiting for an excuse
to do that and here it is um what i'm
about to play for you this is a vlog
from barbie's instagram account
yes the plastic toy has a vlog and an
instagram account
and by the way if you're wondering
barbie has 1.8 million followers on
instagram
1.8 million people decided that they
needed to keep up to date about what a
plastic toy is thinking and doing
so just more evidence that everybody on
instagram should lose their right to
vote that's my opinion
and tick tock too um okay so here's the
the barbie vlog
description says on today's vlog nikki
talks to barbie about racism
and some of the ways that she's been
treated unfairly because of the color of
her skin
having conversations like this is one of
the first steps in addressing and
combating a systemic problem
together let's keep listening keep
learning
and take action to inspire change
obviously we're in for a treat here um
so let's
let's listen to what barbie and nikki
have to say
barbie and i had a sticker selling
contest on the beach last month
we split up and went different
directions to see who could sell the
most
well while i was on the boardwalk beach
security stopped me three times
what they asked me all these questions
over and over and they even called my
mom
i never told you but that's why i sold a
few stickers that day okay first of all
um
uh a sticker selling contest on the
beach
that's the most random collection of
things you know it's like
it's like i said if i said i was having
a celery eating contest in the woods
like why that and why there
to each their own i guess but but what a
weird thing to do with your time and and
who is on the beach
looking to buy stickers anyway if you
only sold a few stickers it's because
every person you approach probably
thought to themselves what
why would i want to buy a sticker who
sells stickers
i get a free sticker at the dentist or
the bank and even if i was going to buy
one why would i buy it here
where am i going to put it i'm about to
jump into the ocean you want me to buy a
sticker
you might as well be selling toasters on
the beach it doesn't make any sense
it's the last thing i'm looking to buy
in this environment
um listen if i was working beach
security and i i saw a couple of weirdos
selling stickers i'd stop them too
because i'd figure there's something
else going on here
so i'm not buying this racism claim from
barbie's friend i just
i'm not buying it i'm sorry it's a hoax
uh let's see what else she's got
and remember when we were going to join
that french honor club at school
well i made a perfect score on the
entrance test but when the teacher who
didn't know me at all
gave me my results he told me i only did
well because i
got lucky he said he knew i couldn't
speak french that well
what you speak french better than all of
us
why didn't you just stay in the club and
prove i'm wrong i don't want to have to
constantly prove and re-prove myself
yeah i'm starting to get narcissism and
and entitlement vibes here
frankly which is what i'd expect from
barbie's crew
spoiled brats the lot of them uh and uh
okay
let's get to the let's get to the big
conclusion
people did these things to me because i
was black and they made the wrong
assumptions about me
and they don't make those assumptions
about white people like me
and that's not fair because that means
that
white people get an advantage that they
didn't earn and black people get a
disadvantage that they don't deserve
exactly it's really serious some people
even get hurt when others think the
wrong things about them
that's exactly why people are marching
because when enough of us stand together
people pay attention right because
when we don't say anything we're just
letting it
continue yes a really serious problem
she says but the only examples she can
give
are the times she only sold a few
stickers on the beach
and problems in the french club at
school you got to come with more
evidence than that barbie
or nikki whatever whatever the names are
now you might say that
i am the one who should be canceled
because i'm spending my time
on this show and your time debunking
racism claims made by a cartoon
character
and you'd have a point which is why
maybe i'll get away from dissecting the
specifics of these claims uh
and instead ask you to reflect on the
fact that
even your child's toy is is repeating
black lives matter propaganda we're
getting stuff about systemic racism and
white privilege from a children's toy
pretty soon we're going to be at a point
where you walk through the toy
aisle at target and press a button on a
teddy bear's foot where it says try me
and the bear delivers a monologue about
the dangers of
heteronormativity and cisgendered
privilege
and you know of course we can make jokes
about it and and
uh we can always say well it's just
barbie who cares
which fair point but this is one very
small symptom
an example of a larger cultural reality
which is that
radical left ideas have seeped into
every
nook and cranny of society in the
leftist mind
everything i mean everything every last
thing
is a tool to convert the heathen masses
and uh that only means that i have to
keep canceling more and more things
it's a war of attrition at this point
and barbie is the latest casualty
and that's it for me today um by the way
before we wrap up i want to say
uh make sure to hit subscribe while
you're here if you're watching this on
youtube
hit the subscribe smash the like button
i have to start saying stuff like this
now i have no choice
um don't judge me but please do that
and i'll talk to you tomorrow have a
great day godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio was mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
facebook and twitter suppress evidence
of joe biden's corruption
conservatives call to break up big tech
and democrat politicians keep up the
sexual creepiness
with amy coney barrett check it out on
the michael knowles show
[Music]